Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum Chaosradio 259 aus den Zuhause-Studios. Wieder mal, weil es ist noch nicht vorbei. Und deswegen ist es heute auch hier Thema. Wir reden über ein Thema heute, das schon viel beredet wurde, das also fast schon zerredet wurde. So auch der Vorwurf einiger KritikerInnen. Trotzdem ist noch mal notwendig. Wir reden heute über die Corona Tracing App, die es ja noch gar nicht gibt. Aber zumindest das Konzept und die Idee davon, beziehungsweise mehrere miteinander widerstreitende Konzepte, vor allen Dingen ein zentrales und ein dezentrales. Und in dieser ganzen Diskussion gibt es so einen Punkt, der kommt da schon vor, aber der wird zumindest für mein Gefühl, wurde der immer nur gesagt, der ist halt da, da nicken alle mit dem Kopf. Manche sagen, ja vielleicht ist gar nicht das Richtige. Aber die großen Diskussionen gingen jetzt beim Contact Tracing, also die Frage, Leute haben Dinge auf ihrem Smartphone, dann werden Daten eingesammelt, die senden irgendwie Codes hin und her. Und dann kann man dann rausfinden, wer mit wem zusammen war, der möglicherweise infiziert war. Da wurde dann immer darüber geredet, wie werden diese Codes generiert, dass die möglichst anonym sind? Wo werden die gespeichert? Nur auf dem Gerät oder in einer zentralen Datenbank? Wer soll das eigentlich machen? Soll der Code-Quell offen sein? Alles total wichtige Fragen und auch wichtige Diskussionspunkte. Nicht umsonst waren die so im Rampenlicht. Aber es gibt die eine Sache, die, wie gesagt, für mein Gefühl so ein bisschen lapidar mitgenommen wurde. Das Ganze soll über Bluetooth laufen. Die Handys tauschen also über Bluetooth-Daten aus. Und daher weiß man dann, wer wen getroffen hat, aber anonym. Und dieses Bluetooth, das ist ganz spannend. Also kann man sich einmal fragen, was ist denn das, dieses Ding? Das haben wir alle in unserem Handy. Da könnte man vielleicht nochmal ganz allgemein raufgucken, was ist das überhaupt für eine Technologie? Dann ist die Frage bei diesem Contact Tracing, geht es ja darum, dass gemessen wird, wer in der Nähe war. Geht das überhaupt damit? Und dann ist das ja eine Technologie in einem Gerät. Und wenn man das Chaos Radio hört, dann geht es ja manchmal zumindest auch darum, dass man Dinge zerforschen kann und fragen kann, geht da was kaputt unter Umständen? Kann man da Unfug mitmachen? Oder was wäre, wenn böse Menschen sich wirklich Mühe geben? Und genau all das wollen wir heute besprechen, und zwar mit den beiden Gästen, die heute hier zu Gast sind. Und das ist einmal Jan und einmal Jiska. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. So, die sind beide vom Fach. Neulich haben wir gerade einen Vortrag gehalten auf dem D-Walk. Und Jiska ist beim Secure Mobile Network Working Lab an der TU Darmstadt, dort als Postdoc, also forschte in dem Bereich. Und Jan ist jetzt IT Security Analyst und Researcher, hat aber seine Master's thesis zu Bluetooth Firmware Analysis geschrieben. Ihr seid also wirklich sehr tief drin. Okay, die kurze Frage ist eigentlich beim Chaosradio immer Anzünden ja oder nein?
Ich habe es also lange Zeit nie genutzt. Jetzt habe ich Kopfhörer, dafür benutze ich es häufiger. Aber ich muss auch sagen, ich habe halt einfach, ich vertraue dem Handy eh nicht. Also ich habe da keine kritischen Daten drauf, keine Passwörter, keine Zugangsdaten, nichts, was irgendwie mit Geld zu tun hat. Weil ich einfach auch irgendwie sage, das ist so ein Mobile-Device, das man halt immer mit sich rum trägt, was in jedes W dann reinkommt, das ist eh kaputt.
Okay, dann lass mich die Frage umfrollen. Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass alles außer Bluetooth an deinem Smartphone oder an Smartphones unfassbar super sicher wäre. Nur Bluetooth ist so, wie es jetzt ist. Würdest du es dann ändern oder wäre dann deiner Einschätzung immer noch dieselbe?
Bluetooth kommt halt schon mit so ein paar Problemen. Also ich sag mal so im klassischen Fall, wenn du es einfach nur anhast und es redet, du bist halt nicht per se sichtbar, zumindest auf den meisten Smartphones. Da gibt es auch ein paar andere, bei denen das so ist. Sobald du Bluetooth anhast, bist du für jedermann sichtbar. Also ja, also wenn du halt nicht sichtbar bist, dann geht es halbwegs. Von daher würde ich es vielleicht noch anlassen. Aber sobald jemand halt anfängt mit einem zu reden, kann es halt kritisch werden. Also sobald man anfängt, nach Geräten zu suchen, sobald man sichtbar ist, wird es halt kritisch. Weil? Kann kritisch werden. Also zum einen, also wir haben uns jetzt halt mal irgendwie die Firma so ein bisschen genauer angeguckt und die Firma ist halt letztendlich auch einfach nur ein Programm. Es kann halt Fehler haben. Und wenn du halt dann irgendwie Kontrolle über den Chip bekommen hast, dann bist du halt da drauf. Dann kannst du sämtliche Kommunikation von Bluetooth mitlesen, kannst Kontakte lesen. Das ist prinzipiell schlecht und du hast halt auch nicht so wirklich Zugang dazu. Also du bekommst die Firmware schlecht runter, du kannst nicht sehen, ob da jemand überhaupt drauf ist. Die Sicherheit von diesen Firmware-Chips ist halt eher so aus den 90ern. Das sieht eigentlich eher schon so ein bisschen grausam aus.
Aber was heißt das? Heißt das, wenn ich mir sozusagen irgendwie durch die Appstores oder Playstores streife und mir dann irgendwie das lustige neue Solitär runter lade, dass ich mir dann irgendwas einfange, weil da ein böser App-Programmierer Dinge zugreift oder ist das so ein Angriffspunkt, ich mache Bluetooth an und dann hat irgendwo jemand eine kleine Antenne und strahlt Dinge aus über Bluetooth, die ihm Zugriff auf meine Firmware erlauben?
Das ist dann eher so, also ein konkreter Fall, wenn man jetzt irgendwie nach Geräten sucht und irgendwie ein böswilliger Mensch ist gerade in der Umgebung, dann gibt es halt unter Umständen Wege auf den Chip zu kommen und das ist natürlich schlecht und wir haben auch Wege gefunden, dass du halt auf das Android-Phone selber kommen kannst, also jetzt gerade für Android selber drauf kommen kannst und da ist dann natürlich irgendwo vorbei.
Wie, was nochmal, also ich mache mein Handy an. Mein Handy sagt so, hey, ich bin hier, gibt es irgendwo Bluetooth-Geräte, meldet euch und dann sagt der böswillige Betreiberin, ja hier bin ich, du bist tot.
Ja genau, so was geht. Gerade ging, wir hatten Sachen gefunden, aber die sind mit der Zeit zum Glück behoben, zumindest für die Geräte, die jetzt Updates bekommen.
Kann man das so niedrigschwellig erklären, dass wir es heute hier verstehen, wie das funktioniert? Also was da genau schief läuft, dass man nur weil jemand sagt, hallo hier bin ich, auf einmal Zugriff auf mein ganzes Handy hat?
Also jetzt in dem Fall war das letztendlich für Classic Bluetooth, nicht für Low Energy. Und da war das halt wieder dieses klassische Problem. Ich würde ein Paket empfangen wollen, das hat halt irgendwie 200 Bites. Ich allokiere mit oder ich sage oder belege mir einen Speicher 200 Bites und dann werden halt einfach mehr reinkopiert als da rein gehören. Und dann fange ich halt an, Daten im Speicher zu überschreiben, die halt nicht überschrieben werden sollten. Und dann kann man, ja, kann man witzige Dinge tun.
Das ist dieses, wie heißt das, Buffer-Overflow?
Genau, Buffer-Overflow, Memory Corruption.
Also das ist, ich versuche mal, wie kann er ein Bild, ich glaube, ich hatte mal, irgendjemand hatte in irgendeiner der vergangenen Sendungen schon mal ein schönes Bild dafür. Aber letztlich ist es also, man, man eigentlich, also wenn alles sauber laufen würde, könnte ich nicht mehr Informationen annehmen, als mir eigentlich zustehen. Aber weil ich das kann, wird dann quasi in Dinge reingeschrieben, wo dann jemand anderes guckt, hey, was stehen hier für Befehle drin? Und dann kann ich sozusagen das deswegen übernehmen.
Also ja, klar, man kann natürlich immer erst mal sagen, so wenn jetzt alles perfekt, absolut fehlerfrei umgesetzt wird, dann ist alles gut. Das klingt eigentlich erst mal solide. Aber der Standard ist jetzt nun halt sehr lang, er ist komplex und es passieren halt einfach Fehler bei der Umsetzung. Und die Fehler können halt, also gerade, also vieles wird halt ins C geschrieben. C ist jetzt nicht die best oder sicherste Programmiersprache und da können halt kleinste Tippfehler halt schon sehr problematisch werden manchmal.
Dieser Fehler, den ihr da gefunden habt, war das so ein Ding, wo man sagt, naja, okay, das ist ungeil, dass es so ist, aber das kann passieren oder ist das Hände vorm Gesicht zusammenschlagen, weil da einfach jemand unsauber gearbeitet hat?
Also ich finde es immer schwierig, Leute zu blamen, es ist einfach so, dass Fehler passieren. In dem einen Fall war ich letztendlich selber auch faul, muss ich sagen, und ich wollte halt ein Längsfeld verändern und habe da nicht genau anstande geguckt und dann habe ich letztendlich irgendwo denselben Fehler gemacht, den der Entwickler gemacht hat und dadurch habe ich halt seinen Fehler gefunden, weil es dann plötzlich der Chip kaputt gegangen ist. Also von daher, ich kann die Faulheit verstehen, weil jetzt jedes Mal in dem 3000 Seiten-Standard nach irgendwelchen Paketformaten suchen, ist halt aufwendig.
Und jetzt ist das ja aber, was ihr da gefunden habt, das ist eine Sicherheitslücke. Und das kann ja mal passieren, jetzt ist die Frage, ist Bluetooth eher so das frühe WhatsApp unter den Funk-Technologien in meinem Smartphone oder hat das einen schlechten Ruf unter Sicherheitsforschern? Wie ist das so ganz generell?
Also wir hatten da so ein bisschen was gefunden. Also jung ist es ja jetzt auch nicht mehr gerade. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wann es hochgekommen ist. Ich glaube irgendwann 90ern oder so. Also es ist halt nicht mehr jung, aber es ist halt, ich sag mal jetzt in der Regel halt auch kein Protokoll, was irgendwie groß exponiert ist. Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, dass jetzt mal mit irgendwie normalen Netzwerkverkehr vergleichen, jeder von uns geht ins Internet, das redet permanent mit irgendwie unauthentifizierten Services, das ist halt bei Bluetooth in der Regel nicht so. Also wenn ich mir jetzt mein Handy mit irgendwie meinen Kopfhörern pair oder mit meinem Fitness-Tracker, dann redet letztendlich mein Handy im Normalfall nur mit meinen Devices und im Normalfall bin ich auch nicht sichtbar. Das heißt, diese Technik ist halt einfach nicht so exponiert und dadurch halt auch gegebenenfalls nicht so getestet. Und wenn man die jetzt dann natürlich in gewissen Kontexten einfach komplett offen macht und dann plötzlich Handys anfangen untereinander zu reden, ist das unter Umständen halt problematisch.
Weil ich habe jetzt eine Verständnisfrage und zwar, wie du es gerade gesagt hast, scheint es so zu sein, mein Handy kann gleichzeitig mit Geräten verknüpft sein, also zum Beispiel meinem Funkheadset, aber für den Rest der Welt unsichtbar sein.
Unsichtbar, also ich sag mal so, wenn ich jetzt nach Device suche, dann muss das Device mir halt aktiv antworten, so hey ich bin hier oder das Device muss halt selber sagen, so hey, hier bin ich, verbinde dich zu mir. Das ist dann halt so vom Protokoll mäßig her quasi, du bist sichtbar. Allerdings natürlich klar, wenn ich halt anfange, teure Hardware auszukaufen und wirklich mal den Datenverkehr auf dem Physi-Calayer, also letztendlich wirklich mit einem teuren Radio mitschneide, bekomme ich unter Umständen halt schon mit, okay hier ist ein Bluetooth-Gerät und kann halt unter Umständen auch Rückschüsse auf die Adresse ziehen, aber das sind halt nicht so ganz so trivial wie einfach nach Geräten zu suchen und das ist halt auch eine Technologie, die jetzt vom klassischen Smartphone, oder?
Aber das verstehe ich trotzdem nicht, also Bluetooth ist ja eine Funk-Technologie, ja, und es gibt eine Verbindung mit einem Kopfhörer und das heißt, mein Telefon sendet Bluetooth-Signale aus zu dem Kopfhörer, um miteinander zu kommunizieren, um zum Beispiel die Musik hinzuspielen, die ich gerade hören will, so das wird per Funk ausgeschaltet, das heißt, das ist ja also dann auch im physikalischen Raum, das heißt, andere Geräte, die erreichen ja diese Bluetooth-Signale und unsichtbar müsste doch dann eigentlich heißen, das Gerät sieht zwar das Bluetooth-Signal, sieht aber auch, das ist nicht für mich gedacht und das Gerät will auch gerade nicht gefunden werden, ich gucke quasi nicht hin, das ist also, Das kommt mir eher so vor wie Augen zu halten. Oder wie stelle ich mir das falsch vor?
Genau. Dieses Augen zu halten ist allerdings schon relativ tief in der Firmware erst mal integriert. Also da muss man halt schon die Firmware selber modifizieren, dass man das überhaupt mitbekommt. Und zweiter Punkt, der eigentlich hier relevanter ist, ist das, was wir vorhin noch gesagt hatten, das sogenannte Frequency Hopping. Das heißt, ich habe halt irgendwie 80 Kanäle und ich habe halt eine zu viele Gesequenz, mit der ich über diese Kanäle einmal rüberspringe. Und dann halt die Chance, dass man dort ein Paket trifft und dann braucht man noch mehrere Pakete in der Folge, dass man entsprechend Rückschlüsse ziehen kann. Das ist halt technisch nicht ganz so einfach.
Das heißt, wenn das in der Firmware da ist, das heißt, der Hersteller eines Gerätes oder des Betriebssystems, der könnte das Gerät dazu benutzen, aber eine App zum Beispiel nicht, weil eine App sozusagen spricht nur mit der Bluetooth-Firmware und muss dann sozusagen das nehmen, was die Firmware ihr gibt.
Genau, also auf der Firmware läuft dann, also auf einem Controller läuft ein Programm und eigentlich nur der Hersteller von diesem Bluetooth-Chip ist dann halt in der Lage überhaupt so was durchzuführen.
Okay, dann hab ich das besser verstanden. Ach so, genau, dann die Nachfrage noch, wenn das so ist, kannst du dann vielleicht noch einen Schritt genauer erklären, was dieses, wenn das Gerät sagt, hey Leute, hier bin ich, heißt das dann, dass es auf einem bestimmten, gibt es dann irgendwie in diesem Frequenzspektrum einen Kanal, der ist der Hallo-Kanal und dann melden sich dann die Geräte oder strahlen darauf aus oder wie funktioniert das?
Bei Bluetooth Low Energy ist es in der Tat so, dass es da letztendlich so einen Hallo-Kanal gibt oder ein paar Hallo-Kanäle, wo dann halt immer mal wieder Geräte sagen so hey, ich bin hier. Und wenn ich dann nach Geräten suchen möchte, dann gehe ich halt auf diesen Kanal und höre einfach meine Zeit lang zu. Bei Classic Bluetooth ist es halt so, dass das Gerät, das halt gerade scannt, erst mal letztendlich überall wieder fragt so hey, ist jemand da? Und wenn zufällig mal eine Kollision da ist, dann sagt das andere Gerät so ja, hier bin ich und kriegt so dann entsprechend die Response.
Das müssen aber beide Geräte wollen?
Ja, das müssen beide wollen.
Okay, dann habe ich das verstanden. Dann ist ja noch die andere spannende Frage, wenn das Angriffsszenario, das eine, das wir hatten, war ja, das Gerät sagt hallo und jemand ist böswillig dabei und kann dann sozusagen solche Fehler wie, du zum Beispiel gerade oder wie ihren gefunden habt, machen. Die andere ist ja, wenn ich mich mit so einem Gerät verbinde, wie ist denn das, wenn das Gerät bösartig ist?
Also wenn man jetzt wirklich sagt, verbinden mit Pern, ist es halt so, dass man über Bluetooth halt schon, also kennt man ja manchmal, dass dann so gefragt wird, möchte die das, darf dieses Device auf deine Kontakte zugreifen, also prinzipiell Kontakte kann man zugreifen.
Auch noch Tethering, Internet, also da hängen ja sehr viele Services mit drin oder auch Tastatureingaben, also es gibt ja ganz viele Dinge, die Bluetooth kann.
Na, aber das ist ja sozusagen, da muss man dann entweder das zulassen, dass das so ist, oder?
Ja, genau, also in der Regel schon. Es gab Anfang letzten Jahres, ich glaube unter dem Stichwort Bad Bluetooth oder so, es gab jedenfalls unter Android das Problem, dass es damals, also es ist inzwischen auch gepatcht, aber dass es möglich war, dass ich z.B. einen Pairing anfange als Headset und wenn das Headset dann irgendwann sagt, na jetzt bin ich aber auch Tastatur, dass es auf einmal plötzlich auch Eingaben machen konnte als Tastatur. Das heißt, auch da können natürlich Logikfehler passieren und generell kann man sich das halt erstmal so vorstellen von der Angriffsoberfläche oder von der Protokolltiefe auch, in dem wir tief die Pasa sind und wie viele Sachen vielleicht irgendwie gegen komische Angriffe verhuntbar sind. In dem Moment, wo ich einen Pairing habe, kann natürlich im Pasa viel mehr erreicht werden und viel mehr an irgendwie ich prüfe irgendwas nicht schief gehen.
Wie ist das mit so Angriffen, wo ich versuche bereits bestehende Pairings zu übernehmen oder mich da reinzuklingen? Also ich stelle mir so etwas vor wie, hey, der hat ein Bluetooth-Headset, das finde ich voll interessant mitzuhören, was der so redet. Deswegen mache ich ein Device, das so tut, als wäre es auch sein Bluetooth-Headset und klone einfach die Information. Geht das oder ist die, wenn die erstmal ausgehandelt haben, dass sie miteinander reden, ist die Verschüsselung da so stark, dass man da eigentlich nicht reinkommt?
Also im Idealfall, wenn halt alles sauber implementiert ist und jetzt keiner irgendwie beim Pairing dabei war, der böswillige Dinge getan hat, kann man in der Regel schon davon ausgehen, dass die beiden Geräte halt irgendwie dann kiesig ausgehandelt haben, die Kommunikation verschüsselt ist, damit halt erst einmal nicht abhörbar. Und wenn ich mich recht erinnere, wird auch abhängig von diesem Key halt, oder abhängig von geheimen Informationen, dann diese Hopping-Sequenz mitgefolgt. Das heißt, ich kann A einmal die Daten nicht entschließen und B bin ich ohne massiven Aufwand auch nicht mal in der Lage, diese Daten überhaupt zu entempfangen. Und ja, wenn ich jetzt dann einfach sage, so hey, ich bin hier ein Headset, dann würde halt unter Umständen das Handy hingehen, würde versuchen, sich mit dem zu perren, merken, okay, der Key, den er hat, der stimmt irgendwie nicht und dann einfach das Pairing verwerfen.
So, gibt es jetzt bei diesem oder andersherum, doch erstmal Bluetooth Low Energy, ist das sozusagen grundsätzlich was anderes oder all das, was wir jetzt gesagt haben, trifft mehr oder weniger auf diese beiden Klassen von Funksignalverarbeitung zu?
Also Bluetooth Low Energy in den oberen Layern, also wenn es dann so Richtung Betriebssystem geht, hat dann schon sehr viele Gemeinsamkeiten mit Classic Bluetooth, aber sobald man dann halt weiter runtergeht, also gerade mit wie funktioniert das Scanning, wie funktioniert das Connection Setup, da sind die beiden Protokolle doch eher, oder die beiden Klassen schon eher unterschiedlich.
Das heißt auch, es gibt andere Dinge, die kaputt sind, oder?
Einmal gibt es andere Dinge, die kaputt sind, ich sag mal so auf Firmware-Ebene, aber auf den höheren Ebenen, gibt es dann halt auch eher gemeinsame Dinge, die kaputt sind.
Ich kann mich gerade nicht entscheiden zwischen so, also vor allem was sie gesagt haben, das klingt schon eigentlich alles ganz plausibel und auch relativ gut abgehangen, ich kann meinem Headset schon vertrauen, und eigentlich klingt das so, als ob das gar nicht mehr ganz wäre. Wie ist denn das jetzt so im Gesamteindruck als Technologie, so Bluetooth, ja oder nein? Also wird es, oder andersrum, ist Bluetooth, wo man deiner Meinung nach noch weiter dran arbeiten kann? Oder ist das, wo du sagst, also eigentlich bräuchten wir für die Aufgabe, die Bluetooth gerade so wahrnimmt, mal was komplett Neues?
Also ja, komplett neu, also das Zeug ist halt schon irgendwie historisch gewachsen, aber komplett neu, also etwas neu bauen, das birgt halt auch immer die Gefahr, dass dann irgendwie wieder viel neuer Code auf kurze Zeit entsteht, der dann halt wieder Fehler hat, also ich glaube halt irgendwie, sich den Kram mal richtig sauber angucken würde helfen und gerade halt dieses Problem, dass man dann irgendwie letztendlich ein Firmwetschip hat, wo halt irgendwie Software draufläuft, die ich mir nicht mehr angucken kann, das ist natürlich so ein bisschen problematisch. Also im Idealfall natürlich irgendwie so offene Hardware wäre eigentlich mal ein schönes Konzept, wenn es irgendwie mal umgesetzt werden könnte.
Wie ist denn das jetzt, um zurück zum Thema der Sendung zu kommen, wir haben also diese Tracing-App, die ja jetzt im Prinzip macht, Bluetooth Low Energy und zwar ständig am Gucken, wer ist denn da in der Nähe? Ist das ein besonderer Angriffspunkt oder ist das nur ein weiterer Use-Case für Bluetooth Low Energy und deswegen nichts Besonderes?
Also, ich würde sagen, für klassisches Bluetooth Low Energy, wenn du wirklich nur dieses Scanning machst und jetzt nicht anfängst, mit Devices zu reden, ist dieses Bluetooth Low Energy Scanning eigentlich unproblematisch.
Aber du musst doch mit Devices reden, oder? Weil, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist ja die Idee des Contact Tracings, dass man diese pseudonymen Zahlen kurz austauscht. Das heißt, da muss irgendeine Art von Kommunikation stattfinden, oder nicht?
Ja, aber ein Weg. Also ich höre einfach nur zu, wer ist da und nicht. Ich rede mit jemandem und frage, wer bist du und was hast du heute gemacht?
Achso, okay, in meinem Kopf war das sozusagen eine Kommunikation, aber im Prinzip macht jedes Gerät gleichzeitig. Es endet aus, ich bin ABC und es hört zu, dass andere Leute rufen, ich bin BID. Aber das ist sozusagen nicht eine Hin- und Herkommunikation, sondern zwei getrennte Einwegkommunikationen.
Ja, also das ist nämlich genau der Teil, wie das in der Google und auch in der Android API dann eben laufen wird, dass es nur über Advertisements ist. Und genau dieser Teil, dass es nur Advertisements sind, ist das, was unglaublich wichtig ist, um eben Exploitbarkeit zu verhindern. Also genau dieser Teil und es ist auch so der Angriff, den Jan auch halt implementiert hat und so weiter und der jetzt auch online ist. Das ist einer, der mit Bluetooth-LE-Advertisements so nicht funktionieren würde. Und der war ja schon bekannt. Also ich mein, Reported hat ja den Anfang November. Und das heißt, dass sowohl auf Google als auch auf Apple-Seite denen durchaus bewusst war, dass es diese Sorte Angriff gibt und dass man eben auf gar keinen Fall aktive Verbindungen nutzen sollte, um eben genau den Angriffstyp zu verhindern. Jetzt ist es aber natürlich so, dass mit einer aktiven Verbindung auch immer mehr geht. Also im Sinne von, wenn ich eine aktive Verbindung habe, dann kriege ich vielleicht auch nochmal genauere Messungen hin, dies das jenes. Aber eben immer um den Preis der Angreifbarkeit auf der Protokollebende.
Das heißt also, wenn man bei diesem ähnlichen Szenario bleiben würde, dann müsste man, wäre jetzt sozusagen ein Punkt, wo man gucken würde, ist dieses so, also ich schicke ja als Information die Stärke mit, wie ich gesendet habe und ich schicke auch meine ID mit. Das heißt, das sind die Dinge, wo man sagen könnte, okay, wenn die Art und Weise, wie der Empfangende sich das ins System schreibt, wenn da irgendwas falsch gemacht werden würde, wäre das ein Angriffspunkt.
Ja, aber das ist eben nur eine Einweginformation und man fängt jetzt nicht an eine aktive, also man hat ja keinen Rückkanal, der fehlt eben an der Stelle. Und für einen Angriff brauche ich, je nachdem, aber für die meisten komplexeren Angriffe brauche ich eben einen Rückkanal, wo häufiger was hin und her geht und die nächste Antwort von der nächsten Anfrage usw.
Also genau, das war jetzt sozusagen mein Denkfehler. Ich hatte jetzt gedacht, aha, der hat ja gerade erklärt, wenn ich da eine Information in den Speicher schreibe und das an die falsche Stelle tue, dann kommt das System durcheinander. Aber weil das nur diese eine kleine Information ist, wo das passieren kann, bringe ich bestenfalls das Betriebssystem aus dem Tritt, kann aber nicht ein System übernehmen, weil ich gar nicht genug Informationen übertragen kann, um Programmcode mit zu liefern, der da ausgeführt wird.
Also da muss man erstmal ein bisschen unterscheiden zwischen, ich würde mal sagen, Firmware und dem Betriebssystem. Also das, worüber wir eigentlich reden müssten in dem Zusammenhang, ist halt ASLR, also Address-Base-Anomisierung. Und das sieht halt so aus, dass wenn wir uns den Speicher von einem Programm angucken, dann haben wir so etwas wie Adressen, das heißt, jedes Byte im Speicher hat halt irgendwie eine Nummer, wo es halt liegt. Und auf der Firma ist es halt so, dass es ein relativ einfacher Chip ist, und da ist es halt statisch. Das heißt, ich weiß genau im Speicher, was wo liegt. Und da prinzipiell geht es dann halt schon so über einen, also einfach nur zu sagen, einfach nur einmal zu senden, dass ich halt gezielt Dinge im Speicher überschreiben kann und damit dann halt irgendwie mein Ziel, was ich als Angreifer verfolgen will, auch irgendwie nutzen kann. Und bei Android oder bei allen Betriebssystemen, auch Windows, Linux, Mac OS etc. Es ist halt so, dass für die Prozesse dieses Adresslayout randomisiert ist. Das heißt, ich als Angreifer, ich weiß halt nicht, wo Sachen im Speicher liegen. Und das ist halt eine essentielle Information, die ich halt brauche, um Angriffe durchzuführen. Und wenn ich halt nur eine Einwegkommunikation habe, dann bin ich halt nicht in der Lage, von dem anderen Gerät irgendwie Informationen zurück zu bekommen.
Und meine Frage wäre, die Einwegkommunikation ist so gestaltet, dass ich mittels dieses... Also ich sende eine Information auf einem Weg dorthin. Und das ist nicht genug, um das Gerät dazu zu bringen, mir was zurückzusenden, obwohl das eigentlich gar nicht soll.
Also das Einzige, was du halt hättest, das wäre halt irgendwie dieses Advertisement, was halt das Handy sendet, aber du weißt halt auch nicht, wo es liegt. Das heißt, du kannst es irgendwie nicht überschreiben und nutzen, um irgendwie Daten zurückzubekommen von dem Device. Das ist halt so ein Henne-Ei-Problem. Rein theoretisch, unter irgendwelchen witzigen Umständen wäre es unter vielleicht möglich, aber es macht es einfach um Größenordnung schwieriger, überhaupt so einen Angriff selbst theoretisch überhaupt nur sich auszumalen.
Das andere Bedenken, das ich hätte, wäre ja so ein Privatsfern-Gedenken. Nämlich, wenn mein Gerät die ganze Zeit sagt, ich bin hier, ich bin so und so. Das so und so ist ein pseudonymisierter Code, der auch ständig geändert wird, also der wird nicht. Was mich aber frage ist, wenn man Bluetooth, also aus einem Netzwerk habe ich gelernt, also wenn wir über WLAN oder verkabeltes Netzwerk sprechen, dass die Geräte, die Netzwerkkarten, die haben noch mal eine eigene Adresse, eine sogenannte MAC-Adresse und die ist eigentlich auch immer mit dabei, wenn Kommunikation stattfindet. Was ich mich jetzt frage ist, wenn mein Smartphone den ganzen Tag in Zukunft nichts anderes macht, dann zu sagen, hey, ich bin hier und mein Pseudonymakod ist jetzt ABC und fünf Minuten später ist er BDE und so was, gibt es da überhaupt keine Daten, dass irgendjemand dazuhören kann und dann irgendwann auf die Idee kommen kann, Mensch, ich kann doch eigentlich genau rausfinden, wo er die ganze Zeit ist, wenn ich an verschiedenen Stellen der Stadt zum Beispiel einfach zugehört habe, was Smartphones da so adverteisen.
Also erstmal sowas wie Mac-Adressen, das gibt es auch in Bluetooth, die sehen eigentlich auch mehr oder weniger genau so aus, sind so zeitlang. Aber wenn wir jetzt wirklich sagen, wir machen nur Low Energy Advertisements und keine aktiven Verbindungen, Low Energy bietet halt auch die Möglichkeit, a, einmal die Adresse zu randomisieren und b, halt auch noch eine Adresse dann oder von einer Adresse zu senden, wo halt keine eingehenden Verbindungen erlaubt werden. Wenn wir jetzt halt wiederum sagen, wir machen erlauben Verbindungen, dann kann ich halt auch mit dem Handy vielleicht reden und fragen so, hey, was kannst du eigentlich und was sind deine supporteten Features und alles Mögliche und kann halt darüber dann gegebenenfalls die weiße Finger printen. Aber wenn ich halt ein Paket sehe von einer random Adresse, wird es halt schwierig da Rückschlüsse ziehen zu können.
Gibt es da in den Konzepten, die jetzt verhandelt werden, eine Festlegung auf ein oder anderes Konzept?
Also es geht tatsächlich darum, dass man zufällige Adressen hat etc. Also genau die Idee ist, dass man anonyme Advertisements hat, die nicht connectbar sind und so weiter.
Okay, da sind wir also auch safe. Vielleicht?
Also wenn es zu verwende...
Nein, du!
Also wenn es zu verwende wird, dann ist es safe.
So, dann sind wir, also ich weiß nicht... Ach so, eine spannende Sache noch. Es klingt jetzt alles ganz gut, aber morgen ist auch noch ein Tag und dann findet vielleicht doch irgendjemand irgendwas, wie man alleine durch Bluetooth-Advertisements im Low-Energy-Bereich unfassbar viele Dinge anstellen kann. Also interessant wäre ja fast schon, also man muss ja nicht immer das Gerät übernehmen. Manchmal vielleicht reicht es ja, wenn ich meine Adresse auf einem seltsamen Art und Weise mache und das andere Gerät kommt so durcheinander, dass es sich ausschaltet. Da habe ich also eine Denial-of-Service-Attacke, in dem ich einfach durch die Stadt laufe. Nur eine theoretische Möglichkeit.
Also alleine fürs Ausschalten musst du schon ziemlich weit kommen, weil normalerweise, wie gesagt, ist es realistischer, was zu finden, was nur im Chip ist. Und dann geht der Chip kurz aus, der rebootet innerhalb von, keine Ahnung, ein, zwei Sekunden und der Bluetooth-Demon restartet sich auch. Also bis du was findest, wo das ganze Handy sich neu startet, da musst du schon ziemlich fies im Treiber hängen.
Ja, aber folgen sie mir. Irgendjemand findet raus, wenn der Bluetooth-Demon startet, dann gibt es ein Ding, was passiert, und wenn ich weiß, dass das passiert, dann kann ich das machen und so weiter und so fort. Worauf ich hinaus will ist, vielleicht findet irgendjemand irgendwas Schlimmes. Und dann ist ja die spannende Frage, wie schnell sind eigentlich die Hersteller der Geräte und der Betriebssysteme, wenn solche Sicherheitslücken rauskommen und die gepatcht werden? Also wenn ich jetzt Jan das von dir gehört habe, letztes November, das ist halt irgendwie zugemacht worden, oder andersrum, das ist doch erst mal vielleicht gefragt, wenn jetzt so eine App kommt, die wahrscheinlich auf mindestens 70% aller Smartphones, das ist ja die Forderung, 70% ist glaube ich die Zahl, wenn alle die Contact Tracing App haben, dann ist das sinnvoll. Das ist doch ein ziemlich interessanter Forschungsgegenstand, oder?
Also die Sache ist erst mal die, wo ist überhaupt diese neue Schnittstelle drin? Und unter iOS ist es eben so, dass die Geräte sehr schnell upgedatet werden und die wenigsten Leute haben irgendwie ein unglaublich unupgedatetes altes iOS. Die meisten sind einfach im Auto-Update und kriegen das über Nacht, wenn da was Neues kommt. Unter Android kann das komplizierter sein, aber jetzt wieder die Frage, wo ist die Lücke? Und das ist eben so, dass soweit ich es verstanden habe, das AP-Update, weil eben sehr viel so zugänglich ist unter Android, über den Play Store kommen wird. Und somit ist es eine Sache, also die meisten Dinge sollten relativ gut fixbar sein. Wenn es jetzt was unter Android auf Betriebssystem oder Chip-Ebene wäre, dann kann es eine Weile dauern.
Das ist ja generell, wenn ich so denke, was Leute über die verschiedenen Handybetriebssysteme sagen, also habe ich zumindest im Kopf, dass es bei Android immer so ist, es gibt immer so die aktuelle Generation, die relativ gut versorgt wird. Aber gerade die alten Geräte sind wohl so, dass da oftmals auch jahrelang irgendwie nichts passiert.
Ja, also bei Android, es hängt auch so ein bisschen damit zusammen, wenn wir jetzt eine Lücke haben, wird sie jetzt gerade aktiv ausgenutzt oder nicht. Wenn sie jetzt neu ist, nicht ausgenutzt ist, dann kann es halt, wie in unserem Fall schon mal gilt, jedenfalls 90 Tage dauern. Wenn jetzt wirklich aktiv etwas ausgenutzt wird, gerade in dem Corona-Kontext, was sehr viele Leute betrifft, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass Google selber relativ schnell einen Patch rausbringt. Dann kommt jetzt das Aber, dass die Vendoren, zum Beispiel jetzt Samsung, dann erstmal dann natürlich das Update, was dann sowieso schon öffentlich ist, wo halt man auch sehen kann, was wurde geändert, dann auch erstmal nehmen muss, es muss es lokal anpassen. Das dauert nochmal erstmal zwei Wochen selbst für die aktuellsten Smartphones. Und für die älteren Smartphones, also älter heißt halt irgendwie, die vielleicht anderthalb Jahre alt sind, die bekommen dann halt in der Regel nur noch quarterly Updates, das heißt alle drei Monate, was schon mal ein relativ langer Zeitraum ist. Und wenn es halt irgendwie älter als zwei Jahre ist, dann bekommst du eigentlich gar nichts mehr. Und das ist halt auch noch so ein gewissermaßen Problem, dass jetzt halt auch irgendwie viele Leute mit Handys rumlaufen, die lange keine Updates mehr gesehen haben. Und in dem Zusammenhang ist halt natürlich dann irgendwie Bluetooth und ich rede mit allem, also wirklich jetzt reden mit, ich verbau eine Verbindung auf, unter Umständen eine relativ schlechte Idee.
Aber es ist auch generell an der Stelle, wo ich schon sagen würde, ja, Bluetooth ist eine schlechte Idee, wenn ich ein Smartphone habe, was schon lange keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr gesehen hat. Aber auch im Internet surfen und auf irgendwelche Links klicken ist eine unglaublich schlechte Idee, wenn ich mein Handy schon lange nicht mehr abgedatet habe. Das heißt, das ist einfach so ein bisschen so, was ist eigentlich gerade mein persönliches Aluhut-Level. Und es ist eben leider so, dass Sicherheit eben tatsächlich kostet, und zwar den Preis, dass man aktuelle Chips hat und ein aktuelles Betriebssystem. Und das kostet eben Geld tatsächlich. Und auch, dass der Hersteller eine Updates rausbringt, auch das, da steckt ja jemand dahinter. Und das sind alles auch reale Kosten, die irgendwo dahinterstecken.
Na ja, aber da kommen wir dann schon irgendwann auf den Anzündenbereich, weil dann müsste man vielleicht doch wieder den Kapitalismus anzünden, weil es gibt ja einfach Leute, die können sich das gar nicht leisten. Das ist ja so, also ja, im Prinzip klar, weiß ich, wenn ich ein aktuelles Smartphone habe, dann ist das sicherer. Aber das ist ja schon so, dass wir in der Gesellschaft leben, wo wir jetzt sagen, also es gibt jetzt diese App, die solltet ihr gemöglich alle haben, wir verpflichten euch nicht gesetzlich, aber der soziale Druck ist schon ganz schön groß, dass ihr euch das jetzt mal bitte alle installiert. Das ist schon, finde ich, eine Zwickmühde, die nicht so ganz einfach ist.
Ja, also ich muss halt auch sagen, also wenn man jetzt mal irgendwie guckt, was so aktuelle Smartphones kosten, reden wir, keine Ahnung, so als Preis mal 500 Euro, als schöne Runde Zahl, hält dann irgendwie zwei Jahre. Das heißt, ich zahle dann letztendlich pro Jahr 250, also pro Monat letztendlich 20 Euro, dafür, dass ich dann hoffentlich halbwegs aktuelle Updates bekomme. Das ist halt natürlich ein schöner hoher Preis.
Das neue iPhone SE 2 kostet 400 Euro und das kriegt vermutlich eher eine 5 Jahre Update.
Ja, wenn es halt 5 Jahre hält, ist es ja auch noch ganz gut. Ich meine, jetzt irgendwie regelmäßig neue Smartphones herstellen, ist jetzt auch nicht sonderlich gut für die Umwelt irgendwo. Und da ist glaube ich dann gegebenenfalls wirklich so die beste Methode sagen, so ok, Hersteller, war nett mit dir, ich bügele jetzt was eigenes rauf. Was allerdings natürlich auch nicht für jedermann zwangsweise eine Lösung ist.
Wäre es denn dann sozusagen eine Idee oder bessere Idee zu sagen, wir lassen das mit der App, das kriegt einfach jeder so einen Token, so einen Schlüsselanhänger?
Ich weiß nicht gerade nicht, wie die Hardware-Lieferzeiten aus China sind oder ob wir das hier lokal herstellen können. Also wenn es dann halt auch wieder Monate dauert, also klar, wenn ich so einen Token habe und im Zweifelsfall was passieren kann, ist halt, dass der Token hochgenommen wird. Also dann sind zumindest keine persönlichen Daten wie Kontakte, Chatverläufe oder so betroffen. Er hat auf jeden Fall natürlich einen Sicherheitsvorteil, aber jetzt halt auch umweltstechnisch betrachtet, kostentechnisch betrachtet, da müssen wir gucken, was die Dinger kosten. Und wie lange das überhaupt dauert, so etwas zu realisieren, das stelle ich mir schon nicht gerade unaufwendig vor.
Okay, also diese Bluetooth-Finder-Devices, die es halt schon gibt, also die haben natürlich noch nicht die passende Firmware, aber die sind so im Kostenbereich von irgendwie 10 bis 30 Euro oder so. Aber das wäre halt was, was man sich nur dafür kauft und so. Also es ist halt wieder so, es ist das wert, weil ein Handy habe ich ja eh.
Ja, wäre die Idee, ob man nicht, ob der Starter nicht sagt, ne, also hier, da ist dein Token. Deswegen die Frage, dann würde das vielleicht zwangsweise, ah, das ist deine Bluetooth-Diskussion, vielleicht in einer anderen Stelle fühlen. Ich nehme aus dieser Bluetooth-Diskussion auf jeden Fall mal ein Ergebnis mit, was mich auch an den Rest der ganzen Sache erinnert, nämlich, also im Prinzip, wenn man so ganz die freie Wahl hätte, würde man das jetzt nicht unbedingt wollen, aber im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten, die wir haben und der Situation, die wir uns gerade befinden, ist es nicht die allerschlechteste Idee. Kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Ja, also, ich glaube, die Daten, die man da halt gewinnt, können halt schon auf jeden Fall helfen, das Ganze unter Kontrolle zu kriegen. Und ich weiß nicht, wenn halt der eine oder andere sowieso noch ein altes Smartphone rumliegen hat, was nichts kann, ist es vielleicht auch ein guter Zeitpunkt, das mal zu recyceln.
Oh Gott, ich hab noch so ein 100-Euro-Smartphone von vor acht Jahren oder so was. Kann bestimmt Bluetooth. Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Bei acht Jahren kommen wir langsam in die Region.
So, habe ich euch jetzt alles gefragt oder habt ihr noch Dinge auf dem Herzen gesagt, da müssen wir auf jeden Fall auch noch drüber sprechen? Yes, sehr gut. Okay, dann vielen Dank, dass ihr heute da wart.
Ich sehe gerade noch irgendwas, blinkt noch im Hack-In. Moment, Moment. Tolle Tipps, kauft ja ständig neue iPhones.
Kapitalismus anzünden ist die andere Variante, die steht immer auch immer offen. Jiska und Jan, vielen Dank, dass ihr heute da wart. Es war mir ein großes Vergnügen, dass ihr meine und ich hoffe auch die Behörer in eure Fragen so geduldig beantwortet habt. Kann man euch irgendwo folgen, euch zugucken, dreht ihr irgendwo auf demnächst? Kann man euch lesen, habt ihr Blogs? Na ja, auftreten, ihr wart auf dem Divog, dieser verteilten Konferenz vom Club. Das war auch ein Auftritt in diesem seltsamen Internet, von dem wir mal reden. Nein, aber kann man... Ich weiß auch nicht, ich habe nur davon gehört. Keine Blogs, Twitter-Accounts, wo ihr euch selbst empfehlen wollt.
Ich habe den öffentlichen Adnerdine, also N-A-E-H, wie das Nähen, also der Nähner sozusagen. Da müssen die Leute aber auch darunter leiden, dass die Hälfte der Tweets ich übers Nähen twittere und die andere Hälfte ist halt technisch. Und ich weiß nicht, Jan nutzt Twitter nicht so wirklich.
Also ja, ich weiß nicht, ich twitte halt irgendwie selten. Der ganze Trend ist mir vorbei gegangen. Also keine Ahnung, bollack42 findet man irgendwie. Also GitHub eigentlich. Da hatte ich auch mal irgendwie so aus dem Blog angefangen, der aber auch seit Jahren keine Abwärtsmöglichkeiten mehr gesehen hat. Gut.
Man könnte dir auf GitHub folgen. Vermutlich akkurater.
Okay, das kann man die Show notes schreiben. Und die andere Frage ist noch, wenn jemand diese Sendung gehört hat und noch nicht genug hat, sondern ein bisschen mehr sich tief in dieses Thema Bluetooth, Bluetooth LLE einlesen will. Habt ihr so eine Quelle, wo ihr sagt, das ist vielleicht für den interessierten Enthusiasten möglicherweise ein guter Anfang?
Ich meine, wir haben so ein paar Talks, also auf Medialzitze CDE, da ist ja auch der von Jan dabei, da sind ein paar von mir. Bluetooth ist halt sehr, sehr, sehr komplex.
Also wird auch schnell komplex.
Ja, wenn man sich einfach nur für Security interessiert, dann muss man halt eigentlich 3000 Seiten lesen.
Okay, ich sage, wir belasten das erstmal bei den Vorträgen, verlinken die vielleicht auch noch in den Show Notes. Danke euch nochmal recht herzlich, dass ihr heute da war. Da wart. Mal gucken, was das so alles bringt. Das freut mich sehr. Liebe Hörerinnen, dann verabschieden wir uns von euch. Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart. Und wir hören uns vermute ich mal in einem Monat wieder. Und mir bleibt heute nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.